more than 20 000 people outside this
prison in Pretoria are trying to prevent
the release of a man they consider an
apartheid Criminal
after serving nearly 30 years for the
1993 assassination of anti-apartheid
leader Chris Hani Janus walus has been
granted parole he was arrested along
with now deceased politician Clive Darby
Lewis who was convicted of conspiracy to
murder
our government want to release the
person who killed him and even today I
was still asking ourselves how to
release a person who killed our hero and
leave people who fought for strugging to
be where we are today but you want to
release a murderer
hours before this protest and on the eve
of his release Wallace was stabbed in
prison by another inmate prison
officials say he's in stable condition
Wallace has for years applied for parole
after serving the minimum time required
and for years it's been denied
but the Constitutional Court ruled last
week that he should be released on
parole within 10 days
the Hani family along with many South
Africans have always opposed his release
they say while he may be remorseful he
has never explained who ordered the
killing and why he did it
the anus today is being granted parole
and we felt let us mobilize all our our
women because
the wife to Chris she is a widow today
her children are without a father and we
as women we stand behind her it can be
right that a woman has to suffer all
because
took away the life of krizani who was a
freedom fighter who was fighting for the
rights of South Africans
Africa honey was a leader of the South
African Communist party as well as The
Liberation party the African National
Congress observers describe his killing
just months ahead of South Africa's
first Democratic elections that
dismantled racial segregation as pushing
the country to the brink of Civil War
[Music]
many are calling for the court to
reverse its decision
even after so many years it remains a
wound for many South Africans who have
unanswered questions
especially since few people have been
held accountable for crimes committed in
the name of apartheid familiar Al
Jazeera